in this video we'll be talking about
Central versus peripheral tolerance in
context of the immune system this is a
highill topic for usml step one so stay
tuned till the end immune tolerance is
broadly divided into two subgroups
immune tolerance is a mechanism by which
immune system ensures that there is no
autoreactive t- cells or B cells that
can harm the own body there is Central
tolerance and peripheral tolerance
mechanism Central Toler occurs during
the development of the immune cells and
it happens within the thymus or in the
bone marrow for the B cells that means
all the mechanisms are happening in the
primary lymphoid organs whereas
peripheral tolerance operate in the
peripheral tissues like lymph node or in
the
circulation so moral of the story is
Central tolerance happens primarily in
the lymphoid organ during the time of T
cell and B cell development vment
whereas peripheral tolerance happens
when the cells Escape Central tolerance
and it's kind of like a fail mechanism
and it happens in the periphery or in
the peripheral
tissues now let's talk about the
mechanisms underlying Central uh
tolerance and peripheral tolerance so
negative selection ensures self
tolerance of te- cells in the thymus in
a moment we would be elaborating on that
in case of peripheral
tolerance there are suppressive t- cells
known as t- regulatory cells which can
prevent autoactive t- cell formation
there are mechanisms known as clonal
energy there are mechanism known as
peripheral deletion which eliminates
autoactive cells from the periphery now
let's delve into details now we are at
the thymus which is
the uh which is the school for t- cells
t- cells develop in the thymus and the
thymocytes present
self antigens to the t- cells t- cells
should supposed to detect these antigens
if they cannot detect antigen as t-
cells they are futile but in cases where
t- cell detect the self antigen with
very high Affinity that is
detrimental those cases are eliminated
by apoptosis and this is known as the
negative selection mechanism that
operates in the
thymus just like t- cells
B cells can also recognize self antigens
during its immature B cell stage where
the B cell receptor is supposed to
recognize
antigens now autoreactive B cells are
those cells which recognize self antigen
with very high Affinity so that is why
they have to be eliminated with
apoptosis and in case of B cells there
is one thing that happens that is known
as receptor editing in this case the B
cell receptor is completely Chang
changed and it is ensured that the
Affinity toward self antigen is low only
then these non-reactive B cells can
survive so now we understand be it t
cells or be it B cells in both the cases
Central tolerance eliminates all the
autoreactive immune cells and thereby
protecting our body now we are moving
towards peripheral tolerance remember
peripheral tolerance happens outside the
primary lymphoid organ
so when self-reactive t- cells somehow
escape the central tolerance mechanism
it is ensured that there is another faep
mechanism which is the peripheral
tolerance which can operate and delete
these uh autoreactive cells so it's kind
of like an immune checkpoint there are
many players and molecules which are
involved in this process one of the key
player is t- regulatory cell t-
regulatory cell secretes inhibitory cyto
kindes or anti-in inflammatory cyto such
as interlukin 10 TGF beta which renders
the t- cell inactive also T regulatory
cell upregulate interlukin 2
receptors which scavenge most of the
interlukin which is necessary for the t-
Cell Activation thereby depriving those
cells from cyto mines and thereby the t-
cell becomes inactive or
energic there could be also inhibitory
receptors such as ctla4 btla Etc whose
interaction with which who whose
interaction with the antigen presenting
cell actually ensures the inactivity of
the antigen presenting cell if the
antigen presenting cell is inactive then
further t- Cell Activation cannot
happen also sometimes it is known that t
regulatory cell secretes perforan
granzyme that might lead to apoptosis of
that autoactive t- cells many of the
mechanisms regarding these t- cell
peripheral tolerance is new and this is
in detail covered in ku's Immunology 7th
edition but
anyway it is important to know
that the te- cells undergo a process
known as clonal deletion that means one
particular clone of the tea cell would
be eliminated and other te- helper cell
clone would remain in this case you can
see there are bluish uh T cells and the
greenish te- cells these bluish t- cells
would be selectively eliminated they
cannot get activated upon re
stimulation and the activity probability
becomes very low but it is not true for
or generalized for the entire immune
system other te- cells which recognize
some other antigen for example these
green ones they would be activated they
have no harm in terms of getting
Activation so that tells us this
peripheral tolerance mechanism is
extremely
specific now there are also activation
induced death of the t-
cell uh I mean there are negative
stimulation there are lack of il2
induction these two factors lead to
upregulation of proapoptotic genes in
the tea cells that lead to its
destruction also t- regulatory cells
secretes perforin granzyme there could
be fast Lian and fast interaction that
might lead to apoptosis ultimately the
result is elimination of autoactive
cells just like T cells B cells can also
be Auto reactive so B cell uh activation
happens in the lymph node and in this
case there are two dedicated signal
which is important for the B Cell
Activation once activated it can
clonally expand and trans and there are
processes like Affinity
maturation clust switching which lead to
the differentiation of the B cell into
antibody secreting plasma cell imagine
these antibodies are autoactive
antibodies so that would be detrimental
for our body right so that is why when
te- cells are basically eliminated from
the system which are autoactive B cells
cannot be activated but anyway there are
many other mechanisms by which B Cell
Activation and antibody production can
be abrogated these are peripheral
tolerance mechanism so just like t-
cells B cell can also undergo energy or
apoptosis when there is autoactivation
of the B cells but even after all these
cells Escape both Central and peripheral
tolerance this is almost impossible to
overcome but some cases this lead to
autoimmune disorders so failure of
Central and peripheral tolerance is the
key cause of autoimmune disorders so I
hope this video was useful if you like
this video give it a quick thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
see you in next
video